[Musique]
bonjour claude on est ravi de vous à
voir en vrai sur ce plateau dans jour
dans la boîte en vrai en personne dans
cette matinale alors on va parler de la
guinée ce matin avec ces concertations à
vue qui ont débuté est-ce que selon vous
elles peuvent aboutir ou y at il un
risque de tensions je crois que le temps
est suspendu à conakry parce que
finalement les militaires qui ont déposé
le président alpha condé ont plutôt été
bien accueillie par la population qui en
avaient assez d'un régime corrompu
inefficace
également le président condé qui avait
modifié la constitution pour pouvoir
faire un troisième mandat qui
s'avérerait problématique
il a plus de 84 ans donc la population a
finalement bien accueilli les militaires
avec une sorte de soulagement mais
maintenant évidemment il faut il faut
reconstruire et
le colonel qui préside la junte en
quelque sorte pas sa semaine à consulter
c'est assez extraordinaire il a publié
hier un communiqué disons qu'aujourd'hui
consulterait les partis politiques et
les responsables religieux demain la
société civile et le patronat après
demain les compagnies minières et
vendredi je ne sais pas qui d'autre je
crois qu'on a rarement vu des
putschistes faire un programme de
concertation s'étalant sur toute une
semaine c'est aussi pour gagner du temps
certainement car il est en train
d'essayer de constituer un gouvernement
qu'ils puissent à la fois contrôlé
présenté comme un gouvernement d'union
nationale puisque c'est ce qu'il a fait
ce qu'il a promis ça sera peut-être pas
facile compte tenu de ce qui vient
d'être dit d'ailleurs c'est que les
guinéens ont aussi leur caractère et
d'ailleurs monsieur sékou touré l'avait
montré en 1958 en étant le premier
président d'afrique francophone le
disant je veux l'indépendance et je la
prends tout de suite il avait mal reçu
le général de gaulle à conakry donc la
guinée ça n'est pas facile c'est par
ailleurs un pays à pays potentiellement
très riche puisqu'il est le premier
producteur de bauxite
à des mines d'or des mines de diamants
il y a des ressources hydrauliques
considérable un potentiel électrique
aussi qui pourrait être exporté ailleurs
en afrique un potentiel agro alimentaire
qui est inexploité et ce pays en effet
potentiellement riche n'est pas riche
parce que la gouvernance et les très
pauvres et que l'instabilité politique a
toujours été là alors que l'autre cette
instabilité politique justement quelles
conséquences sur les relations
régionales avec les organisations on
pense notamment à la cedeao la cedeao
est très embêté parce que ça fait deux
fois qu'un phénomène de ce type arrivent
en un peu plus d'un an l'année dernière
c'était le mali au mois d'août
maintenant c'est la guinée alors bien
entendu il faut condamner parce qu'un
coup d'état c'est pas bien il faut
recourir à des élections et demandé le
retour à un processus constitutionnel
c'est que c'est ce que la cedeao a fait
et dans les deux cas d'ailleurs envoyé
une mission sur place pour étudier les
conditions
la ministre des affaires étrangères du
ghana était vendredi dernier à conakry
elle a vu l'ancien président alpha condé
elle a dit qu' il était en bonne santé
qu'on n'était pas maltraités et donc
elle fait rapport à ses mandants à la
cedeao qui va examiner s'il ya lieu de
prendre des sanctions économiques contre
la guinée je ne crois pas qu'elle le
fera la guinée est simplement suspendu
de tout le système de décision de la
cedeao c'est un peu la même chose à
l'union africaine est évidemment les
africains ne peuvent pas cautionner un
coup d'état mais en même temps ils ne
veulent pas tuer l'économie d'un pays
déjà très fragilisée qui a vécu sous
perfusion du fonds monétaire
international et qu'en est il des
relations avec l'europe par exemple et
notamment la france alors avec l'europe
monsieur borel a fait son travail c'est
la condamner le coup d'état mais pas
bien mais
il a dit qu'il fallait évidemment
remettre en liberté le président alpha
condé mais c'est tout pour les
missionnaires ont la vie ne veut pas
démissionner pour le moment l'europe
probablement et un va examiner s'il faut
suspendre la haine ou ne pas le
suspendre
mais l'aide elle profite à la population
surtout pas pas nécessairement régime
alors en tout cas la partie de l'aide
qui va directement à la population sera
maintenue pour le reste il faut voir
quelles sont les garanties que donnera
le nouveau pouvoir et c'est un petit peu
ce qu'ils aient site cette semaine dans
ses consultations avec la france la
situation est la même le gouvernement
bien entendu ne peut pas cautionner un
coup d'état le gouvernement doit dire et
la vie il faut libérer monsieur alpha
condé mais en même temps il faut
rétablir
les possibilités de croissance
économique de ce pays qui a un potentiel
très forts aléas des plus forts de
l'afrique de l'ouest eh bien merci
beaucoup l'autre blanche raison pour cet
éclairage ce matin dans la matinale un
éclairage à retrouver bien évidemment
sur les réseaux sociaux fois